you've been told your whole life if you
follow the one normal path everything's
going to be all right and it's not
working you took out the loans you got
the job you got the degree you moved to
the city to follow your passion and now
you're here the math and your fantasy is
not adding up if you want to break this
cycle of anxiety and money in your life
you must choose reality choosing reality
is about owning how life and the world
truly is not stomping around and
complaining about how you wish it would
be own it this is how much you owe this
is what it actually costs to live in
this city this is what it will cost to
safely buy a home this is how much this
job actually pays period of course you
want new cars and kids in the right
schools and vacations in just a home and
there's a snake on every corner that's
going to loan you the money to get those
things right now even though you can't
afford them choosing reality is about
being honest about who owns you